cop 26 finished late last night and
we're still plowing through the wealth
of detail but the immediate reactions
were mixed to say the least
i'm joined now by labour's shadow
business and energy secretary ed
miliband good morning mr millband in
trouble
two weeks of talking and um some say
that yesterday was a substantial
breakthrough others say cop was a flop
where are you on this
well i would say that after glasgow
trevor 1.5 degrees keeping 1.5 degrees
alive is
frankly in intensive care and it's our
job
in the next 12 months to show that we
can
save it the reason i say that is because
the task of
glasgow the task of the world is to
halve global emissions over the coming
decade that's by 2030 that's what the
scientists tell us is necessary to keep
1.5 degrees alive
and the truth about glasgow despite
some progress
is that the world is only probably about
20 or 25 of the way to that goal so
there is a chasm now
between where we need to be
in halving global emissions
and all major countries have to step up
and play their part in that and where we
are
you've actually said that the developed
countries have a particular
responsibility to those countries which
are still developing uh essentially that
countries like britain uh european
countries and so on uh have the bigger
burden uh to play here did yesterday's
result
tell you that we fa that we in developed
world have uh failed in that uh in that
responsibility or have we succeeded
i think we are dragging our feet really
in a very problematic way you know you
know i was part trevor of the 2009
copenhagen
summit the equivalent of glasgow's
summit yesterday
and at that summit a promise was made to
developing countries which is to
developing and vulnerable countries that
the 100 billion dollars of finance
public and private finance will be
provided to them by the richer world and
this is about an existential crisis that
so many of these and countries are
facing and so many of them talk so
movingly at these talks about the fact
that that their countries will literally
disappear if action is not taken well
the problem is that
more than a decade on
this finance has not been delivered and
the key thing trevor is that there isn't
just a moral reason to do that there is
also frankly a self-interest reason
because the reason that the paris summit
of 2015 succeeded
in a way perhaps that glasgow didn't is
that an alliance was built of vulnerable
countries on the one hand and developed
countries like ours on the other
to to drive forward ambition and also
put pressure on big countries like china
to act now now because in the final
hours of this summit
developing countries were still arguing
about whether this hundred billion would
be provided i'm afraid that coalition
wasn't properly formed and i just have
to sort of say as i have nothing but
praise for alex sharma at who you're
having on later on and the job he did as
co-president but i'm afraid the rest of
the government didn't help him and
undermined him with decisions like
cutting overseas aid because we were
then saying to other countries please
step up on climate finance when we were
stepping back on aid to poorer countries
well whether the rest of government
helped or not let's just deal with what
happened yesterday had you been sitting
in alok sharma's seat
and the indians and the chinese and
nobody seems to be mentioning the
australians had
turned up and said look this phasing out
cold's got to go let's
have a phrase like phasing down what
would you have done would you have
accepted that or would you have said
i'd rather have no agreement than this
agreement
well look i'm very hesitant to second
guess alok because i think he's done
done an amazing job to be honest and i
think he's impressed people around the
world with his diligence
and his commitment and his integrity i
wish that the um chained last minute
change hadn't been made but i wasn't
privy to those discussions i think there
is a wider lesson here though which is
we need to do more to put pressure
on all of the big emitters uh frankly um
that includes india that includes china
it includes countries like australia
trevor you know we're we're doing a
trade deal with australia and we've
agreed to drop the paris temperature
commitments from the the trade deal now
australia is a real lagard on climate
they've got a net zero target to get to
zero emissions in 2050 but it's not
really a proper plan and they've got 20
30 targets
that if every country was doing what
they're doing would take us to four
degrees of warming now that would be
catastrophic for the world if we ended
up in that position so i think part of
the lesson of the what you know what's
going to be different in the next 12
months compared to the last 12 months is
that
for all countries
the climate policy can't sit on the side
of their other approaches of their other
policies got to be it's got to be at the
heart of what we do we should be
rewriting that australian trade deal we
should be saying to australia look i'm
afraid if you want to be part of the
club of nations if you want a trade deal
with us then you've got to step up and
and you know i think it's really
important this that we can't leave
glasgow
was modest progress it wasn't the
transformation we needed but we can't
leave glasgow and and if you like step
back the fight
to really keep 1.5 alive starts here in
the run-up to cop27
well this this comes right to the point
doesn't it
what are we prepared to give up to make
this kind of thing happen because china
and india and pretty much everybody else
can say
always
you know you can yell at us as much as
you like but until you do your part uh
why should we make our citizens suffer
let's just start
the hundred billion that you rightly
referred to
hasn't yet been delivered i mean how how
are the um small
states island states
uh uh uh supposed to believe anything
that we say when we haven't even
fulfilled a pledge from 12 years ago
i mean you are completely right about
this trevor uh you're completely right
and you know it's the hundred billion
and as i say we should restore the
overseas aid cut look look we
cutting overseas aid was the single
worst decision this government made in
the run-up to cop because it undermined
our moral authority it meant that when
we were going to the french the germans
the others and saying please step up on
climate finance they were saying well
how can you tell us to step up you're
the only g7 country at jakarta but you
know it's not just about the issue of
100 billion because 100 billion you know
it might surprise your viewers to know
this the 100 billion is in a sense the
starting point for the cost these
countries are going to face but it's
also about things like vaccination you
know it is a scandal that when you look
across the developing world we've got
one or two percent of populations in
some parts of the developing world that
have been vaccinated and i'm afraid we
haven't the boris johnson said at the g7
summit in cornwall that we would
vaccinate the world by the end of 2022
we are way off that this is an issue of
trust too and you know the whole thing
here abroad and at home is that this is
a matter of collective solidarity this
is a matter of whether we are in it
together we're in it together globally
and we're in together in britain as well
whether we're going to guarantee that we
don't just have ambition in tackling the
climate crisis but we also have justice
and and those two things are absolutely
intimately linked
all right well look i mean i i i hear
what you're saying and you know i feel
your indignation but let's get to the
raw politics of this um the truth is
it's a hard sell
uh for us to do our part uh on this
we have to be talking to our
population about um
new boilers 18 grand a shot
electric cars way more expensive than
anything that anybody gets in
behind the wheel on today uh more
insulation now
is labor going to be saying to the
population look everybody we know this
is going to cause cause us pain but
realistically
we're going to have to bear that pain if
we're going to meet these objectives are
you ready for that
well i'll tell you what i'm going to be
saying and what we have said which is we
have set out a pledge to invest 28
billion pounds extra each and every year
between now and 2030 in tackling the
climate crisis and the reason this
matters to your question trevor is we
have to we have to make this fair for
the population we have to make this fair
for citizens so you know the truth is
that the cost of electric cars are
coming down but we should be giving zero
interest loans to people so that lower
and middle income families can afford
electric cars we should be doing more to
help subsidize people in the transition
to new boil to
to zero carbon heating so that it
doesn't cost people more than a new
boiler and and i'll be absolutely
explicit with you trevor i think it is
right to make this investment now it's
right to borrow to make that investment
and here's the thing this is the prudent
and responsible choice because the
normal argument people make against
government borrowing to invest is that
it will store up debts for future
generations the biggest debt we can
store up for future generations is not
tackling this crisis and there is a
fascinating report from the office of
budget responsibility published in july
which says the costs of climate action
delaying by a decade the cost of climate
action action doubles the overall cost
so acting now is the right thing to do
morally it's the right thing to do
economically and it's the right thing to
do to create jobs in our country to
tackle for your poverty and i'll give
you one very concrete example literally
a national program of home insulation
and retrofit around this country street
by street house by house could cut bills
cut carbon emissions create jobs and
make us less dependent on the on
international gas this makes economic
sense
all right well uh
let's see if there's a pledge that can
be made here
cut emissions by half by 2030 net zero
by 2050 and labor will do whatever it is
whatever is necessary uh to coin a
phrase used by the current chancellor
whatever it takes
to meet the initial outlay for the
consumer and the citizen to meet those
pledges labor will do whatever it takes
we absolutely have to do whatever it
takes you know you know and and actually
we need to go further and faster than
the numbers that you just said and the
reason this this matters is because if
we end up look after glasgow that
scientists tell us that on the base of
the pledges made by countries we're
heading for 2.4 degrees of warming now
that might not that might sound to some
people quite harmless but you know what
it means it means billions more people
facing extreme heat waves
we had terrible floods in doncaster in
my constituency in 2019 and in 2007 it
means more extreme weather events like
that and the other thing is that
this is not i'm not just in the let's
avoid disaster business because actually
by creating by investing we can create
good jobs we can tackle fuel poverty we
can create cleaner air see i think part
of the argument that people like me need
to make this stronger trevor okay you
make the point is is that this is about
creating a better world and a better
life for people all right well let's
bring the people of doncaster into this
conversation
um everybody can say we must do this
everybody can be on the side of virtue
but when you say to them on the doorstep
by the way this is going to cost you
thousands of pounds because because we
have to do it
otherwise you know other people will be
underwater we'll have all sorts of
problems
do they say uh in doncaster yes we
understand mr miliband yes here's i'm
i'm going to start saving now or do they
say oh
not sure about that
i think i'm saying something different
to you trevor and i think this is a
difference between our approach and the
government's approach because we're
lucky in this country that both parties
want to tackle this problem but we've
got different ways
of doing it i'm saying to you that
government needs to make the investment
so that it's financially possible for
people to make yeah but but government's
money doesn't come out of out of nowhere
it comes out of that well out of the
people that vote for you
well i'm saying something quite explicit
to you though i'm saying we borrow now
to make this investment because it will
save money in the long run and it's the
prudent and responsible choice you see i
think the british people are in a very
event you have to pay it back
well yes yes but we'd have to pay a lot
more back if we didn't act you see i
think the british people are in a very
sensible place on this i think they're
saying we want to go green we want to do
the right thing but don't make this a
rich person's luxury make it possible
for us to make this change and we will
come with you and also don't look both
ways don't cut passenger duty for
domestic flights don't do all right
things which suggest you're saying one
thing and doing another
all right just very briefly if i may
every time i've i've asked the question
i'm about to ask you to your colleagues
they've um pre-barricaded
new oil field on the
stream possibly in scotland cambo it's
called a new
coal uh production facility in cumbria
surely after yesterday
labor must now say
neither of those should go ahead
you're right neither of them should go
ahead no prevarication clarity we cannot
have the cambo oil field going ahead
because it's the equivalent of 18
coal-fired power stations running for a
year we should not be having a cut the
new coal mining cumbria frankly it looks
like total hypocrisy when we are trying
to persuade other countries to act
you're right trevor this does change
things we do need to show we're going to
act and we need to show that we're that
we're not facing both ways as a country
that's been the problem with this
government and we need clarity and
strength when it comes to the climate
emergency
ed miliband that is appreciated thank
you very much indeed